I got something I want you to be
thinking about let me tell you what week
this is this is the week where mentally
80% of people check out to the second
week of January let me say this one more
time for most people they're gone for
six weeks Thanksgiving then they get
settled down and twelve the December TV
shows Christmas gatherings all this
other stuff and a holiday becomes a
holly six weeks of just being casual
Black Friday all these other things
Thursday football all these other things
that get caught up with it and you know
what happens to the first quarter most
people have a terrible first quarter
because of the way they treat the
holidays this is all I can tell you I'm
not telling you don't enjoy Thanksgiving
I'm not telling you don't enjoy
Christmas Day I'm not telling you do
that stuff I'm planning on doing it
myself up at the office Thanksgiving
morning but I'll be spending the time my
family in the afternoon and the evening
and I'll be there my family on Christmas
Eve and Christmas have a lot of family
coming over but this is what I will tell
you don't be part of the 80% where
they're gonna be checking out for six
weeks take the two days the rest of the
time stay focused especially if you are
not there yet especially if you're
climbing up the mountain to get to the
top and find out what that wolf on top
of the mountain is really up to but do
you want to go up against that guy or
what do you want to see the best version
of you at the top of the mountain
just remember the Week starts this week
where it's filled with so many
unnecessary distractions because
mentally most people gonna tell
themselves that's okay it's okay thank
you
it's okay solid it's okay it's Christmas
okay it's okay it's okay
only if you're gonna say it's not okay I
got big plans in 2019 my 20 19 starts